what was wanda's head space for you like  moment one of the show like when she  walks through the house doors  where is her head at like i kind of read  it a little like a blank slate  eager to you know seize that opportunity  the  the life that they could build for  themselves in that house absolutely  nothing else  nothing else existed except for it's  like  it's like nothing else exists except  this moment  and us starting anew and and not even  starting new because there is  no other this is just how it is  um it is a complete blank slate as  opposed to a clean slate like it is  nothing was wiped off it was just it's  blank um  and that's how we approached it  and the show um  is what starts to inform the characters  of of other things as it keeps going  you